>> Tucker: WELCOME TO "TUCKER
CARLSON" TONIGHT.
THEY CALL IT THE WEEK THAT
CHANGED THE WORLD.
THAT WAS RICHARD NIXON’S
DESCRIPTION OF HIS VISIT TO
CHINA IN 1972.
NIXON WAS THE FIRST AMERICAN
PRESIDENT TO ENGAGE DIRECTLY
WITH THE COMMUNIST GOVERNMENT,
HE WAS RIGHT IN THE END, THAT
VISIT CHANGED EVERYTHING.
FOR A WHILE, HE TOLD US, IT
WOULD BE GOOD FOR EVERYONEMENT
RELATIONS WITH CHINA WOULD HELP
EVERY AMERICAN, THAT’S WHAT THE
EXPERTS SAID.
FREE TRADE WOULD MAKE US RICH.
THEY CONTINUE TO TELL US THAT
FOR DECADES, EVEN AFTER THE
EVIDENCE MOUNTED, IT WASN’T
TRUE.
EVEN AFTER CHINA ENTERED THE
WORLD TRADE ORGANIZATION AND
ELIMINATED ENTIRE PORTIONS OF
OUR ECONOMY ALONG WITH MILLIONS
OF AMERICAN JOBS THEY SUSTAINED,
MOST OF WHICH NEVER RETURNED.
THE MEDIA, MOSTLY IGNORED THAT
PART, IT DIDN’T AFFECT THEM, AND
THEY WEREN’T INTERESTED.
FACTORY WORKERS COULD LEARN TO
CODE.
AND, IN FACT, SOME WORKERS MAY
HAVE LEARNED TO CODE, BUT THEN
IRONICALLY, CHINA BEGAN THE
WHOLESALE THEFT OF OUR COUNTRY’S
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY, OUR
CODING, WHICH IS THE ONLY THING
WE HAD LEFT ONCE OUR HARD
INDUSTRIES DIED.
THE MEDIA STAYED SILENT AS THIS
HAPPENED.
THEY DIDN’T SEEM ANGRY ABOUT IT.
THEY DIDN’T SEEM BOTHERED AT ALL
BY CHINA’S ESPIONAGE CAMPAIGN
AGAINST THE U.S. GOVERNMENT
WHICH IS THE BIGGEST AND MOST
SUCCESSFUL SPYING OPERATION
SINCE THE COLD WAR.
REPORTERS DIDN’T FIND THAT
INTERESTING EITHER.
THEY SCREECHED ABOUT RUSSIA AND
GEORGE FLOYD AND HOPED WE
WOULDN’T NOTICE ANY OF IT.
THE BIGGEST STORIES OF THE
DECADE, IGNORED.
SO WHY DO WE DO THAT?
WHY THE DECEPTION?
WE CAN ONLY SPECULATE.
BUT WE CAN TELL YOU THERE’S SO
MANY AMERICANS ARE BEING HURT BY
CHINA, INCLUDING HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF THEM KILLED IN
THEIR PRIME FROM IMPORTED
CHINESE NARCOTICS, A SMALL GROUP
OF AMERICANS WAS PROSPERING.
IN EVERY AGE, THERE ARE A FEW
WHO GETTING RICH FROM THE CHINA
TRADE.
IN OUR TIME, MOST OF THESE
PEOPLE HAVE CLUSTERED AROUND JOE
BIDEN.
HE’S THEIR CANDIDATE.
WE’VE LEARNED TODAY A MAN CALLED
BOB AIGER MAY BECOME THE NEXT
AMBASSADOR TO THE PEOPLE’S
REPUBLIC OF CHINA.
BOB I GOER RUNS THE WALT DISNEY
COMPANY.
FEW HAVE MADE MORE MONEY FROM
THE CONNECTIONS AND FEW ARE AS
OPENFULLY GRATEFUL FOR IT.
IT’S TRUE, HE ADMITS IT.
WATCH.
>> TODAY THE CELEBRATION OF
CREATIVITY AND COLLABORATION,
COMMITMENT AND PATIENCE.
A TRIUMPH OF IMAGINATION AND
INNOVATION AND TESTAMENT TO THE
STRONG PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN
DISNEY AND CHINA.
TOGETHER, WE HAVE CREATED AN
EXTRAORDINARY DESTINATION.
HERE, EAST MEETS WEST, THE PAST
MEETS THE FUTURE, AND ANYTHING
IS POSSIBLE FOR THOSE WHO
BELIEVE.
>> ANYTHING IS POSSIBLE FOR
THOSE WHO BELIEVE.
BOB I GOER SAID.
THAT WAS 2016 AT THE OPENING OF
A NEW DISNEY THEME PARK IN
SHANGHAI.
BUT IT TOOK MORE THAN BELIEF AND
FAITH TO GET THAT DEAL DONE.
BOB AIGER DIDN’T EXPLAIN WHAT
DISNEY HAD BEEN WILLING TO DO TO
GET THE PARK OPENED IN CHINA.
ACCORDING TO AN ACCOUNT IN "THE
NEW YORK TIMES," BOB AIGER MET
PERSONALLY WITH CHINA’S
PROPAGANDA MINISTER IN 2010 AND
PROMISED TO USE DISNEY’S GLOBAL
PLATFORM CREATED BY WALT DISNEY,
A PATRIOT, TO, QUOTE, INTRODUCE
MORE ABOUT CHINA TO THE WORLD.
IN OTHER WORDS, DISNEY PROMISED
TO SPREAD CHINESE GOVERNMENT
PROPAGANDA.
THAT’S WHAT THEY DID.
DISNEY BEGAN WORKING DIRECTLY
WITH THE MINISTRY OF CULTURE IN
CHINA.
THAT PARTNERSHIP PRODUCED A FILM
CALLED "BORN IN CHINA."  THE
MOVIE PROMISED TO SHOW CASE TO
THE WORLD THE SPECTACULAR WILD
LIFE AND NATURAL BEAUTY OF
CHINA.
HE ALSO GRANTED THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT A 30% SHARE OF THE
DISNEY MANAGEMENT COMPANY THAT
RAN THE SHANGHAI PROPERTY AND A
57% OWNERSHIP STAKE IN THE
SHANGHAI RESORT INCLUDING
REVENUES FROM MERCHANDISE,
RESTAURANTS, AND HOTELS.
PUT YOURSELF IN HIS POSITION.
YOU WATCHED FOR DECADES THAT THE
GOVERNMENT OF CHINA HAS HURT
YOUR COUNTRY, HURT YOUR FELLOW
AMERICANS.
IF YOU WERE A PATRIOTIC PERSON,
WOULD YOU JUMP INTO BUSINESS
DEALS WITH THE PEOPLE WHO DID
THAT?
BOB AIGER DID. IF YOU’RE GETTING
THE IMPRESSION THAT HE’LL DO
ANYTHING FOR A BUCK, SLOW DOWN
FOR A MINUTE.
THAT’S NOT ENTIRELY TRUE.
HE’S NOT THAT GUY.
HE’S A SENSITIVE SOUL.
HE’S A MAN OF DEEP CONVICTION
AND PRINCIPLE, AT LEAST HERE IN
AMERICA.
HE ANNOUNCED IT WOULD BE, QUOTE,
DIFFICULT FOR HIS COMPANY TO
FILM IN THE STATE OF GEORGIA.
WHY?
BECAUSE THE STATE OF GEORGIA WAS
MOVING FORWARD WITH A LAW TO BAN
ABORTIONS AFTER DOCTORS COULD
DETECT A FETAL HEART BEAT.
HE WAS OFFENDED BY THAT.
HE’D LIKE MORE AMERICANS TO
ABORT THEIR CHILDREN AND HE’S
WILLING TO PAY THE PRICE FOR
THAT HIGH IDEAL.
BUT IN CHINA, THERE’S A SEPARATE
SLATE OF STANDARDS.
CHINA CAN THROW ETHNIC
MINORITIES IN CONCENTRATION
CATCHES, CHINA CAN WELD
CORONAVIRUS PATIENTS IN THEIR
APARTMENTS UNTIL THEY STARVE TO
DEATH, AND HAVE.
THEY CAN CRUSH PROTESTERS ON
TANKS ON TELEVISION, NONE UH OF
THAT BOTHERS BOB.
CHINA HAS IT RIGHT, HE SAYS,
APPARENTLY IN FORCED ABORTION.
HE LOVES CHINA AND HE’S NOT SHY
ABOUT SAYING SO.
>> THEY WELCOMED US THERE AND
LET US BUILD SHANGHAI
DISNEYLAND.
SO WE HAVE A GOOD RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE GOVERNMENT OF CHINA AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN CHINA.
AND THE ACCESS HAS INCREASED
OVER TIME.
GENERALLY, AT LEAST OF THE COO
OF THE WALT DISNEY COMPANY LOOK
AT CHINA QUITE FAVORABLY.
>> Tucker: SEEMS SHOCKING NOW.
HOW CAN THAT MAN BE IN THE
RUNNING.
JOE BIDEN ISN’T THINKING OF
NOMINATING BOB AIGE IN SPICE OF
WHAT HE SAID.
HE MAY NOMINATE HIM BECAUSE OF
SUCKING UP TO CHINA IS THE
QUALIFICATION.
AND ACTUALLY, BOB AIGER IS
FOLLOWING THE LEAD OF THE BIDEN
FAMILY.
OUR REPORTER OBTAINED A 2017
E-MAIL FROM JOE BIDEN’S SON,
HUNTER, TO THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
CHINESE ENERGY COMPANY, CEFC.
THE E-MAIL OFFERS, BEST WISHES
FROM THE ENTIRE BIDEN FAMILY.
IT GOES ON TO URGE THE CHAIRMAN
TO QUICKLY SEND A $10 MILLION
WIRE TO PROPERLY FUND AND
OPERATE THE BUYEDEN FAMILY’S
VENTURE WITH THE COMPANY.
NOW, CE FSHG C, YOU MIGHT
REMEMBER, IS THE COMPANY THAT
OFFERED HUNTER $30 MILLION FOR,
QUOTE, INTRODUCTIONS ALONE,
INTRODUCTIONS TO THE PEOPLE HIS
FATHER WORKED AROUND,
INTRODUCTIONS TO HIS FATHER.
AND THE EQUITY STAKE FOR SOMEONE
CALLED THE BIG GUY.
WHO’S THE BIG GUY.
ACCORDING TO THE EX-BUSINESS
PARTNER, THE BIG GUY WAS JOE
BIDEN.
IF ALL OF THIS SEEMS A LITTLE
TOO BRAZEN TO BE REAL, CONSIDER
THE MEDIA CLASS AND THE SILICON
COMPANIES THEY DEPEND ON FOR
REVENUE OPERATE IN THE SAME WAY.
IT WAS FOUR YEARS AGO TODAY,
DECEMBER 16, 2016, THAT OUR
NATIONAL NEWS MEDIA WAS UNITED
ON ONE POINT -- NOTHING, THEY
TOLD US, WAS A BIGGER THREAT TO
THE SAFETY OF THIS DEMOCRACY
THAN FOREIGN MEDDLING IN OUR
POLITICS.
IT WAS HAPPENING BEFORE OUR
EYES, WE WERE TOLD, AND OUR
PRESIDENT-ELECT, DONALD TRUMP,
WAS PROBABLY COME POLICE IT IN
THAT MEDDLING, NOT BY CHIENACHIN
BY RUSSIA.
A SPECTER OF TREASON HOVERS OVER
DONALD TRUMP.
THE SAME DAY, DECEMBER 16, 2016,
"THE WASHINGTON POST" OPEN BED
BY JEFF BEZOS, CHINA’S BIGGEST
FRONT FOR RETAIL SALES IN THIS
COUNTRY, PUBLISHED A PIECE IN
THIS HEADLINE, QUOTE, FBI IN
AGREEMENT WITH CIA THAT RUSSIA
AIMED TO HELP TRUMP WIN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
AND NATIONAL PUBLIC RADIO, CNN,
NBC, EVERY NEWS ORGANIZATION
DASHED OFF THE SIMILAR STORIES
MAKING THE SAME POINT.
YET NONE OF THESE OUTLETS ARE
SAYING WORD ONE ABOUT THE
E-MAILS WE JUST READ YOU.
THE BIDEN FAMILY’S ATTEMPT TO
GET MONEY FROM OUR CHIEF
ADVERSARY ON THIS WHICH IS THE
GOVERNMENT OF CHINA.
THEY SAY NOTHING ABOUT BOB
AIGER’S PROP GANDIZING IN CHINA.
THEY CELEBRATE THE IDEA THAT HE
MIGHT BE OUR COUNTRY’S
REPRESENTATIVE TO THE GOVERNMENT
OF CHINA.
WHY IS THAT?
BECAUSE OUR MEDIA ARE DEPENDENT
ON CHINA.
THEY WON’T LET YOU VIEW STORIES
ABOUT HUNTER BIDEN BECAUSE THOSE
STORIES ARE ABOUT CHINA.
NEGATIVE STORIES ABOUT CHINA ARE
NOT ALLOWED.
IT’S BECOMING OBVIOUS.
HOURS AGO, A MAJOR DIGITAL STORE
FRONT IN THE UNITED STATES
BANNED THE SALE OF A VIDEO GAME
BECAUSE IT MOCKED THE APPEARANCE
OF THE PRESIDENT OF CHINA THE.
NOT OF OUR PRESIDENT, BUT OF THE
CHINESE PRESIDENT.
THAT’S NOT ALLOWED.
AND, YET, IN THE FACE OF THIS,
JOE BIDEN IS ACCELERATING OUR
SUCKING UP TO CHINA.
INSTALLING CHINESE PROP GAN
DISES IN THE U.S. GOVERNMENT TO
REPRESENT OUR INTERESTS IN FRONT
OF CHINA.
THIS WILL CONTINUE TO HAPPEN
EVERY DAY IN THIS COUNTRY.